[Music]
hello welcome to et live I am Sophie she
lacy joining me today is a very special
guest who you may have seen on the for
last week and you may remember her from
a throwback to Rebecca Black thank you
for being here thanks for having me yeah
so exciting so we gotta talk about the
for last week how much fun did you have
on that show what a day
that was the craziest day ever because
you know there's so much anticipation
and like excitement and then nervousness
and it was it was really really fun and
like this I mean everything since then
it's just been even better than crazy
now of course Megan recognized you
immediately when you came out on stage
and that was one thing that like the
judges reactions I was like they could
have no idea anything about me uh-huh
they could be like why why she here or
weapon sure sure so you had no
expectations of whether they would know
who you were or not
tell me about what Megan's words meant
to you oh my gosh I mean she has and
throughout this entire process just like
continually blown my mind
with how sweet and encouraging because
especially with her like I look up to
her as a songwriter I look up to her as
an artist she's so involved with what
she does which I look up to so much
and sort of have her support me like
it's crazy like even talking about it I
might know it just it almost does it
makes sense to me it's crazy to think
that somebody you look up to can really
just support you like that so yeah
absolutely and I mean you could have
probably had your choice of any show
really there's the voice there's Idol
America's Got Talent like a million of
them and I feel like with the viral
notoriety any of them would have been
happy to have you why did you choose the
four ultimately
well
I first so long was really scared of
those kinds of shows and I never thought
I would do one and I think it was
because oh man like I went through such
a rollercoaster after Friday and and
there were just I really was not ready
to do something like that until the four
just like came into my life and
immediately I was like this could be so
cool like this I'm so excited about this
and I couldn't let go of it and before I
knew it like it just happened
yeah so they approached you to be
involved it was a it was a I don't know
I don't know if it was really that they
I think both sides were kind of like
what if okay
and and we both just kind of followed
our guts I mean what was it about the
reality show competition thing that
scared you before because there is one
shot and if you mess up like they will
probably use it you know because I I had
I'd never done anything like that before
that was another thing that was kind of
scary to me it's like you you don't you
really don't know until you know I know
a lot of people have like speculations
on how those shows go and even I did but
yeah I think it was it was a combination
of that and also really like putting
myself back out there I knew that a lot
of people would be like not only
watching but watching with a very close
ear and I sure which could go either way
really it could be a blessing or a curse
but I mean you brought it so thank you
seemed happy about it yeah and what I
loved actually I went and looked at at
the Friday video today and I saw so many
comments on there of people coming from
watching the for and saying hey I just
came back to like show you some love and
give it a like after the floor that's
gotta be pretty cool it is so so cool
like the only thing that I can say and
that I keep saying is like I couldn't
have even dreamed of this happening you
know like I
on that show to take a risk and really
for myself to like have that I didn't
even realize it until like I started
crying onstage was how healing that was
for for me and also like I hoped at you
know after that and like waiting for it
to air that someone else could watch
that you know like not everyone has
these crazy viral videos I get that and
but what a lot of us do have are these
these times where we feel like an
outcast or rejected or alone and
hopefully if you look to watch that and
really yeah see that you can really make
anything happen I see some fan questions
coming in so I want to get to a few of
those keep them coming you guys deidre
wants to know
she says Rebecca you're adorable how did
you handle mega Fame at such a young age
oh my gosh it was it was overwhelming
because you're 13 I was 13 was seven
years ago yes yes and it was
overwhelming because and of course with
my situation it wasn't just like wow
everyone's watching you is everyone's
watching you and there's a good chunk of
people that really don't like you or
that are telling you to do something
else being vicious ruthless yeah because
the Internet has changed so much and
this does still I still see it happen to
people but you know it was like just
kind of like the wild wild west back
that and people just said whatever they
wanted and there's this idea that we
don't you know the person behind it
isn't gonna see what you actually say or
what you comment but the chances are
they do we all look at our social media
like I mean and it's impossible to look
at a comment and just like be completely
emotionless about it oh yeah I say that
all the time I think anybody who says
that doesn't impact them is lying or
they're lying and I even thought I was
there at one point you're either lying
or if you'd really
you have that happen where you feel like
numb to it I think that is such a more
painful place to be in yeah because then
you get numb to the positive stuff -
yeah that is a really good point yeah so
you talked on the show about your
experience with the cyberbullying and
all of that what is your relationship
like with social media today no um I
mean over the past couple years like I
really it was when I started to are not
even past couple of years but you know I
started with like a YouTube channel and
that allowed me to feel like I had so
much more of my own voice and like to
just I don't know I talked about
everything from like my life to the
makeup I used to how I dealt with some
of Friday stuff and that really really
helped me like feel like I had a safe
place and and it stuff like social media
for everyone I think is tough because
you want to look your best but you also
want to be real and and I go through
that like we all do yeah but I I mean
especially over the last like week it's
been unbelievable every day to like wake
up and see is so much support yeah I
want to know what has your support
system been like through those years I
would guess it was probably family early
on um when you were going through all
the Friday stuff tell me about your your
kind of inner circle that's gotten you
through everything oh man
my mom has always been like my number
one yeah I mean she is incredible from
even before Friday like I was I
I've been performing for my entire life
you know like I was always trying to
find something to have that it's just
where I felt so my most that's so yeah
and and she would take me to everything
and just she knew that I loved it so
much and and yeah I mean I've got a
really like close-knit family and I yeah
I I think even with friends like I've
been lucky to grow that circle and meet
some people who are
also doing the same thing I do and
that's really it's really nice to have
yeah like-minded people but also people
that don't do it too you know got a
balance yeah right yeah what I want to
know after going through kind of this
evolution would you ever consider
recording a new version of Friday I
don't know
well I did see um I have played around a
lot with that song and especially over
the last like I did a I did a tour in
October of last year where I really
wanted to take that song and make it my
own
yeah so we did like a very nineties
slow down dark version and maybe that
maybe that will come to see life one day
okay another question coming from you
guys on YouTube from Timothy would you
ever do a song with Meghan Trainor yes
girl what cameras on Meghan let's go
let's do it that would be so much fun
are you kidding I love it it's such an
amazing songwriter she's incredible are
you guys still in touch um she is very
busy filming before yeah yeah I mean it
has been like the greatest on social
media and just like being yeah now tell
me about your song on the floor bye bye
bye yes why did you choose that one I so
that was like my first idea going into
the show and I had been wanting to do
something with that song I love taking
older songs and making them my own mhm
and of course bye bye bye probably my
first favorite song ever and yeah it
just it just worked and of course like I
think it fit with really what I wanted
to do for the show too like for my own
self and yeah it just worked
and then you followed up with another
like 90s throwback love it I love that
song I love that song so much and that
wouldn't like I mean both of them I was
like oh my gosh I just want to do it
mm-hmm but it was I had so much fun with
them all right give me some
behind-the-scenes scoop from your time
on the show like what are you hanging
out with Fergie backstage like what was
the day it was a long day on set I
understand a long day I mean oh my gosh
what can I say Fergie I will say like I
[Music]
everyone on that show like all of the
judges the panel Fergie
they are so you can tell how much one
that they believed in the show and then
they believed in everyone that walks on
that stage like they want you to win
mm-hm and it doesn't work out for
everyone and everyone is ready for it
but that was what like that's what
really drew me to the show as a fan the
first season was seeing like wow I root
for these people and I know they do too
yeah the nature of the show is really
combative like I think that's what they
sold it yeah yeah but tell me about the
relationship between the contestants
like because as combative as it is it
also seems like y'all were really
supportive of each oh yeah oh yeah I
like walked away with so many new
friends after that because you're
spending a good amount of time like
preparing for everything together and
that day is a really long day yeah I I
mean of course there's like everyone I
feel like there is a bit of competition
but I think it's mostly like you're
competing with yourself and everything
you know manure comes a point where like
you battled someone who's on the floor
so if anything you're kind of like oh I
don't know like what's gonna happen in
here more so like nervous with them than
with each other but yeah everyone comes
from everyone was so different so that's
what's nice is you didn't have to be
like oh well this person is a you know
slightly better or whatever version of
me everyone just came with something
sunny unique yeah absolutely
now even though your journey is done on
the floor I know you're still hustling
and working hard so what's next for you
well I just put out a song
called satellite in the music video
first on called satellite which is I
mean like the timing was just like crazy
with the show but that wasn't planned it
had been planned come on girl I like to
be you know like I honestly it ended up
coming together so well like I've been
working on this music video for half a
year and then like the timing with the
show came out so perfectly but but yeah
I I that's how do I talk about the song
so many times and now I'm it is such a
special song to me because it was like
the first behind-the-scenes moment like
before you know having anything like the
four where I really was able to just
like let go of all of those Friday and
Securities and just be in a studio and
be myself as an artist and yeah I just
adore that song so I hope I hope
everyone can relate to Adam
congratulations
he's excited to check out the video
Jennifer from YouTube wants to know who
inspires you most in your work in my
work it's like in music yeah oh I love I
listen to so much stuff all the time
different things and I love when someone
takes a risk and isn't afraid to try
something completely new like I love
Pharrell and he is like the master at
that I love people like Charli XCX and
Tove lo like these really empowered
girls and pop I love that because I
think that is such a force for right now
and yeah
there's so many I I love this kind of
like movement happening in pop it's
starting slow and I hope people sorry I
probably sound crazy right now but oh I
just love that this was happening or
these women and pop that are not afraid
to do something different and kind of
make pop cool okay well edgy well edgy a
little whether it's edgy or just like
fresh or again I think it's all about
taking risks and not just
trends absolutely and are you working on
a full-length so you are you planning a
tour or anything like that or it's just
all about the single satellite right um
well satellite like is is doing its
thing and I love that and I have been
working on I mean even behind the scenes
like I've shot a couple movies this year
and I'm always writing I'm always there
is one that is a I guess you would call
it a thriller and one that is a and
actually kinda has to do with the
singing competition
okay weirdly enough and yeah I mean I'm
always I again I've got my youtube which
I'm always posting stuff on Instagram
and everything yeah absolutely well
thank you for being here how's it going
to meet ya thank you thank you guys so
much for watching and where can they
follow you on social media um at miss
Rebecca Black MS Rebecca black and
youtube.com slash Rebecca satellite
music videos right there
there you go thank you guys for watching
we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]